you're joining at the right time I think
I'm just about to start I could use
headphones I couldn't figure out how to
cut and connect my ear pods to this like
desktop setup
I tried googling but it didn't work
there's a backup in house ready I do
have a back of mouse somewhere hopefully
I don't break it
Eric Hanson has been treating this mouse
pretty well it's a tea hot it's slightly
warmer than lukewarm I have a challenge
okay
Alexa be quiet okay so the game match
starts now I'm gonna hide the chats and
good luck to my opponents first in half
winner plays fiddler when I alternate
colors okay okay I'm black
expecting d4 no time is lost for a first
move so can show a little bits
Oh am I going to this line yeah I have a
few things I can play here I'll play
Bishop d6 I know he's played this is
black to h6
night at 3:00 let's play with this my
bishops a little bit misplaced on d6
actually she curious what the plan is
here so helps unlike g6 96-97 plan
I could also play Bishop e7 if necessary
you're spending a lot of time though a
bit too much time for the opening
there's Bishop g4 - I think I'll try
Bishop g4 92 92 I could play Bishop e6
Wow
allows me to take takes I'll play a five
keep the tension and c7 not a huge fan
of that line play g5 like weenie
southern how about trying to discourage
before some idea Bishop h5 - bishop h5
to g6 just to try and trade things off
Queen is aligned with the rook it's not
pleasant so takes Knight takes
can take on take there and play g5 let's
do that
some eventual line where the rook is
lost on e one he plays d6 and takes I
take on e1 next move I probably want to
play g5 Bishop takes h2 Wow unexpected
g5 I guess now it's not threatening to
take either thing because I take on you
one I think so Bishop h5 I'll probably
save my bishop in the end Bishop II
Aiden and calculating bishop g3 Bishop
h5 each three Bishop ei takes takes my
rooks not defended though not the end of
the world have other options expecting
each three here o h3 I can still know he
has to do so
Oh was not expecting that two rooks
Bishop e5 move play Brooke just rook
back safe
it's kasev but the skirted this should
be 597 and I bought rocks Bishop f5
coming play this move Bishop a5 Bishop
g6 I'll keep the time advantage
a g4 two rooks if you be five before
some idea you were calf 894 ideas
let's take b5 9 h v i9 h v 1 play night
of 4 and windy 6 let's be safe should
win d6 now maybe this move weakens g5
that prevents h5 I know blundered but
he's long time let's take that check
96 looks okay oh no oh wait Trix Trix
you can't take I have to defend my Flags
all to the score
have a good position okay I know he's
expecting this
you play Bishop a fiver couldn't be six
or six or Bishop g4 or takes there's a
lot of moves here for black any takes
like Queen b3 move this move I think one
of the best moves for some g3 I think of
solid a very similar structure to last
game actually it's going for minority
attack
there's ih4 let's play not h4 wants to
play also played before though let's
play this first
okay cup-like we can see one and then
try and get the night to see five
but the ricany one first
[Music]
a trade-off nights
locks probably a bit better given the
structure before doesn't work bring the
light back to be three going in for c5
if before maybe takes an a4 I might see
five and B three potentially be solid
some g4 idea this later but make c5 will
be a nice square it's hard for a lock to
remove that and then b3 I have a
protective pass a pawn might sack oh he
might go for a five but I'm threatening
to take on c4 I'll smite rooks along
with the Queen so e5 is kind of
double-edged
I want a blender hey this move looks
solid
wanna play b3 soon Oh II five is
playable looks like doesn't play it
maybe rook C 185 looming maybe Bishop b5
97 okay what's maybe three
platfor trying to be restrictive I
thought I'd turn the sound off but
thanks for the son by the way 96 oh no
it doesn't quite work let's play this
move first and take on e4 next you have
for your g4 it's a nice position I'll
keep massaging the rooks oh wow
well I plundered hmm okay put the rook
behind it's still a fight some time
advantage
I'll Queen d2 rook takes e4 didn't fall
for it under time scramble
can you selected okay
tactics yes okay that's what every game
comes down to hoping I don't have a
heart attack all right let me update the
score
[Music]
[Music]
mix it up a little bit douzo following
the game
Draya versus Alamos from 1999 this is a
slightly offbeat line against classical
but it's playable
se6 I think there was another Adams area
of game or had them something game oh he
played c5 at some points 25 maybe and
tries to take on c3
play this move looks reasonable knight
c6 is Queen c7 94 ideas I take
as well yeah oh
I can take in c4 okay it's very
positional now of equal time
rook b8 ideas Bishop G 394 logical let's
play this
the Knights other night comes to d7 he
has Bishop d6 threats this is okay
though
ninety-seven everything should be
defended
[Music]
I'm play rugby eight soon
hmm
surrendering the B file but he can't
really like penetrate anyway in this
move pressure the a pawn
he for very thematic he did this move
bring the king in to help out have 94
now 94 Knight of 6
[Music]
jano tactics
Wow what's my plan a six like I don't
know Ellis to do just be solid and wait
oh he has a plan
please g5g for coming up d1 g for ticks
ticks let's put the king on g6 safer
square
Urich a five looks awkward the defense
things I'm losing upon now I'm not I
ever ticks
let's try and get the night 2f Ono in
the snow too - okie 6 I'm gonna use kind
of waiting positions this is a move I'm
winning oh no I'm not with material or
am I
I'm meeting I'm not I want to play rook
e1 I'll have an eighty two threats and
I'm threatening the rook for tonight's
inaction
I need two coming your rook e1 might be
an idea - I'm you two should be simpler
it's so I'm still gonna be a fight with
two bishops I have time put the rook
there okay I want to take on g4 soon
it's tricky move
[Music]
take their
King is outside the box let's go
two to one it's gonna be a long match
all games have kind of been time
scrambles try this again
and maybe I shouldn't repeat the same
opening
okay it's solid and what should not be
worse here they Bishop e2 leave some
tension trying to make him think it's b5
gonna come
it might okay I can get the light
squared bishop it's got the light
squared bishop I'm playing a four bit
different than last time
hmm
and there's g4g five ideas loves off for
nine out of three and go for the e5
square lucky one
it's one dish 53 yeah the minority
attack is not gonna be pleasant can we
the tension maybe
put the work on d1 and then now they
five is gonna come it's being c4 here
Baba then 95
not so great let's try and survive it's
not a lot of time I might be for ones
upon not good
can switch shift gears I'll try and
focus on the kingside still some life
I'm g4g three kings youtuber Kate want
ideas slow though
it's very slow but maybe five I'll show
that trends but maybe it pressures some
some pressure points Brooksie one ideas
to rook t2 here I'm also like why not
five
so with rook teach in point a five point
h4 let's double up the rooks ah that's a
fork I have 95
should probably take on d2 first with a
rook there's some Knight g5 ideas could
be tricky I don't see how it works so
check King run c7 he's thinking it's
good sign
I'm gonna be down the exchange in the
pond oh wow he was scared to take the
rook but my Brooke is just trapped what
Brooke is just trapped
so I guess king h2 or gg4 try g4 has to
be aggressive I hope it was like I I
last long enough for the game to come
down to time again let's try this in
Queen f4 it's 95 ideas
Chuck I have to plate this up f1
take know I should move back first I'll
Quincy seven ideas 95 first let's try
this
archer 'this leads to much it's an
attempt though
going after e6 suck everything it might
be mates oh hang on the rook wanna play
this
no no I was bad it was close so like I
did fight I did fight that's two to two
okay close match
[Music]
play this again
play this one night h5 might be six
Bishop u6 it's trying to just remember
it supposed to be solid last game I saw
in this was golden chi donna hi donna of
golden from the u.s. senior let's do
this not sure if I'm supposed to throw
in g6
bring the knight back
Queen before ideas night c4 looks
playable 96 maybe pretty balanced
position probably King a when I get the
chance
who it's gonna get sharp so I can play
b5 b6 36
[Music]
I'm Queen before
Queen before she threatening and he's
running something I played b5 here
looks risky but don't see what's wrong
with it when I find Queen c7 Bishop f5
always in the air I don't see how the
sacks work he can sack on c6 or b5 with
some p4 possibilities before 92 [ __ ]
about five I can go in what's going with
this move once the play night before I
want to play maybe off six soon now six
could be nice just throwing punches some
bishops c8 idea
[Music]
okay this is a nice Bishopsgate night
before c5 so when the a pond better when
they a pond
cosplay D 5 D 5 up t7 v a5 coming nice
time advantage healthy rook d7 c5 oh
wait what is this I can take on the Sun
you can see 7 to b6 next plan
he's invading c5 have to allow it oh
let's not hang a look
[Music]
put the rock back
some before before I put the bishop on
b5 maybe hmm confining no I'm not
turning that the rook here
now it's solid I think
let's go for this running Bishop c4
oh no that's pinned does that work check
I can win pawns we got a lot of pawns no
let's not do that
okay Judy flag I mean I was better most
of the game took a lot of time earlier
the tough fights so many time scrambles
a 3-2 to mix up the openings with scheme
[Music]
because he play against us oh he's
expecting d4 so we played I have six
okay let's play a king's indian play h3
Bishop g5 live King f1 the move forget
the exact move me each six is included
expecting a rookie eight you know work
yet thinking of one at some points if I
remember correctly looks weird but it
gets out of check I can take in this
the Queen here should train can that my
rook sumo
or to move the bishop maybe this
diagonal some idea of g4 mm might be
five I'll start with Queen d2
just see what black is up to I have four
[Music]
also taken g3 let's take I'm just trying
to be solid for at some points
once the rooks are connected and then
I'll fight for the e-file block before I
play G for 9:06 King G to looks okay
hmm
how dangerous is this 34 it's a queen
there's f3 but king h2 h3 is kind of
tender not sure where the Queen goes
though I'll put the rook here 3 King H -
I have a g4 now take stakes just trading
and could trade a lot any tactics
switcher we're gonna trade hopefully I'm
not missing any tactics oh no am I
my Queens overworked but I don't think
he can take advantage of it I take your
first maybe even throw in no I can't
throw in rookie 124 so I'll take it's a
bit iffy though King is kind of weak
that's coming to f8 yeah mmm what to do
this move
trying to control the squares and
knights attacking rookie one
and walks into a pin but that's life
I'll be choose falling mmm let's got out
of the pin that's the Knights pinned in
two directions though it's not good
let's play a four
such an ugly move King f1
get away with this
just want to play 96 and enjoy life I
take you three Queen takes g3
everything's defended their work I fail
I take the night's oh yeah this night is
pinned
I'm just getting needed to play this
it's not good it's really not good
it's still weird though feel like
there's some tactic but I don't see it
for luck we have to King d1 I won't play
rookie to next my night is actually
quite strong meaning ideas on g7
forgot I was Czech okay that's life
[Music]
I think I know what I'll play this game
oh okay
guess he knows too
well it looks weird got a six I mean
restricts a bishop you see for Mike um
yeah I just want to play solid ambition
g7 castling
I'll leave my pawn on e4 Roka yet
be six at some points okay not sure what
our plans are just one play fast and
solid Oh use a g5 okay it's actually not
so bad
but the bishop on i-5 and then g6 just
have to watch out for f3 okay d5 maybe
take on g5 start with
it was quindi for not sure what to do
here Troilus takes you 661
I have to be very careful let's play
this for me to this now my moves don't
work okay spending so much time
but yeah I was in trouble still kind of
in trouble
I'll leave the tension
I got away with this might be able to
tense position oh there's a line where I
lose all my queen side pawns that's not
pleasant it's going to be obstacle our
bishops h3 pawn is fixed so it gives me
some hope like later on to win h3 and
push my H pawn I'm clearly worse here I
was expecting this line
ooh Bishop d4 coming I can't stop it
just have to try and survive I won't
play Bishop c8 to take h3
it's my one hope he crushes I hope but
maybe I just drop the rook somehow not
really but kind of and now time is my
one hope now stalemate is my one hope
okay four to three okay
messages let's go rematch a lot more
chess to play try this again I don't
think you intend another six last time
okay I looked at this briefly before the
before the match and this endgame should
be pleasant for whites maybe 8/3 looks
fine I don't play Knight g5 just target
the Bishop h6 good move
my vision d3 I might be three I probably
have to take b3 no I can't
95 doing something
ladies six work
and spending a lot of time his bishop
yeah that's probably not good let's take
the night and plane out of for
and he lose off too but I might win e6 a
positional game slightly worse upon
structure by Bishop versus night's king
c2 Rock f1 is a plan but the rook here
b7 is on a half-open file what to do
Bishop g6 just wins material OS King out
747 though didn't win material in Bishop
f5 know start with this move or d7
Bishop f5 know what I'm doing
try this move had to stop rookie to IG
for what got7
[Music]
she'll bring the bishop back to d3 play
h3 be solid and i g4g 452 93 king
somewhere
not-so-pleasant
eg for at some points have this move
it's gonna be down upon but okay things
are gonna be crazy
maybe you wanna pawn here rookie to King
g3 I'll take with check threading meinen
one please miss it
how does he stop it 91 I guess a rookie
to his kings getting made in the center
almost oh that's how he stops it it's
gonna be a pawn race he gives winning
even like after he promoted he had some
Queen move to stop me when g2 was not
good okay four to four black
ask Amy plate b3 he's mixing it up a
little bit this should be okay it's in a
similar structure that's timeline Bishop
Frankie seven rather than g7 C five if I
want but then he takes I'll put the
bishop on b7 just to reinforce my pawn
whoever challenges it with d3 my bishop
opens up in c5 and c5 looks looks
interesting it's gonna lead to a double
edge position my play Bishop e5 Wow
there's b5
[Music]
what to do
hey let's move thanks for the bits by
the way
what to do here
Queen c7 Queen c7 looks playable there's
pressure against the rook in the end the
Queen probably wants to go to c6
you just take some bishop after three
I've got five ninety five actually night
whatever the night moves to the rook is
vulnerable he's fighting some stuff from
that h5 interesting I'm just hitting the
bishop hand the rook I mean he could go
for a knight c7 I don't know that works
so I like that H five
getting g3 I guess I'll play top five
and there's some possibility of g4 yeah
bring the Queen may be back and around
to h4 g4 again in positions opening up
which should favor the bishops King eh a
grouchy eights or rook lifting start
with rookie six
looking for stuff so I can try this hmm
okay I'll probably have to trade now
let's try the pair of rooks however a ga
coming soon time is becoming more
relevant
probably age 16 age 7
oh maybe I should just offend the pawn
somehow queen g6 and e6 he takes with
rook bishop c8 let's good move after
weather the storm
it's getting complicated
snatcher in Brookes on the board close
match
it's like black I was back in that game
okay
time for efore this is as far as my
preparation goes Bishop c5 I was
studying this and there's a lot of
playable moves here I don't know any
sevens a move and Bishop III was the
main move Bishop c5 engine move I assume
he's he studied this mean engine
actually suggests a lot of moves for for
a white in that position captain to
weather this storm Queen d2 takes I'm
not getting mated should be okay and
then if three should not do anything
but what to do here rook ta coming I'm
Queen c3
it's a dangerous position
I'm sure what to do who's keen D - it's
so ugly but I'll try to make it work
I'll lose G - oh but I have worked g1 in
the end actually with a meat threat I am
up a paneer - but not for long
some tea for maybe
have to try vision t4 I'm not looking so
good though
oh he wants to play this kind of three
move
I take 95
looks very dangerous he's 1:29 3 anyway
[Music]
don't have so much defense just praying
this doesn't lose instantly
[Music]
okay
just pretending now
so I somehow survives but it's still
it's still looking pretty bad
mmm let's play let's move want to
mobilize other rook I leave with other
work I have three maybe breakthrough
someday
don't play a five actually a six
expected yeah
it's time
five and a half okay
I can know all they'll do against b3
reverse London
[Music]
and get away with this
probably not thanks Derek I have to get
a second job because of GFI bids oh
thanks that's nice okay I play a reverse
variation of this it's interesting
oh this probably doesn't work though
night here let's act two pawns for
something
yeah I'll interact with the chat later
this is all business
okay some cup elaichi 594 ideas
I like the position
[Music]
not sure what to do here though
[Music]
h 5 h 5 crazy move but I'll play Knight
g4 it's gonna play Queen f3 I'm not okay
still wanna play Knight g4
mMmmm queenside castling click the rooks
and still on the plane IG 4 and D pawns
coming back where it's hard to remove my
rook on d3
[Music]
bring the King to c6 slow improvements
I'm Bishop before idea was trying to win
the pond
what's a fork
I Bishop d4 this is okay I think that
saves of Han
another time scramble approaching pawns
belong in light squares
there we go very close match its first
28.5 I was black that game okay
go for this again
okay this is a line which I kind of
forgot to prepare before the match I
know he plays it though but this is
interesting I won't play 95 maybe even
queenside castling so he goes for this
trade this is similar to our first round
game a bit different play 83 oh no
wonder okay that's okay let's still
fight play too quickly there
yeah my plans change I was gonna go for
his attack but now I just have to just
keep the game going
okay only down the pond
I'm gonna lose another pawn take sticks
take the Queen
don't go from this guy losing tall now
I'm so bad
have to take he doesn't have any passed
pawns
and not gonna be easy to hold my pawns
are weak
okay
and the rooks are active - I do have a
time advantage that's why my one
advantage in the position is time I have
to milk it like a cow okay keep the
ponds going let's go like this
hmm don't really want to trade rooks
you can't always get what you want in
life
minority is hacking us okay an attempt
was made so you want to keep the a pawn
or C pawn only hold on to one mmm
surprising actually
[Music]
g4 is coming
not good
really not good yeah
okay I tried it's a 25 not sure why it
does that
b-black next game
okay
[Music]
and this is a blitz opening see if he's
prepared
Quincy 294 I think is idea
and he's not prepared you know fish
about five I guess
[Music]
the bishop before
[Music]
hmm
so if I take we can trade a lot my
bishop g6
I'm kind of conceding but okay
and b6 here
can take in Queen d6 one play rook CA in
97
just like untangle g5 thanks Joe for the
sub g5 something life t7 might be safer
the gay force typical okay that's
playable too
in the smooth
hum playbook c7 everything staring at c6
in g5g for
and let's move to
those lights are super superfluous so I
don't want to mess with them too much
let's play this move playing for a win
not g6g six King g7
[Music]
taking on z6i virtue seven in the end
[Music]
I mean this is what I want I think H
files open Rock h8 ideas
Brooksie and ideas to cleanse me of my
gaming of Sam Shanklin from the 2010 US
Junior very similar structure I lost
that game but now the structure is good
here Wow
I have tactics just night back so I
think we need three my g5 24
hmm
counter the pond
play let's connect the rooks
second exchange network messy messy
and white
[Music]
okay go for this again the previous game
face going for the sign again yeah this
was my preparation a3 coming next get
the bishop hair some h3 I don't think
it's necessary though it should be -
maybe now h3 just didn't want to deal
with Knight g4
some castling well Castle and put the
rook here don't think c4 is too
vulnerable
I'll play a four a five a 92 Bishop f3 I
still play a five and then just leave
the tension yeah I like 92 if I get the
chance
it's attacking me cleric c1 or okay
three labor gave three once the way 96
96 92 some c4 ideas now kind of
considered c4 last move
controlling c4 enough times or they want
to push but probably have two might be
seven can be annoying Bishop's not
getting trapped can I'll play five and
then I just leave the tension maybe
Roque one even to come I was black doing
here play a six
not a huge fan of that though let's kind
of leave the tension more tickle the
pawns rook should be on b1
take her okay seven let's try this so if
you dick say five I take twice and when
c5g sort of g3 kingi - ooh
move back
take now don't do much play this
hmm takes with Ponder's would be three
of takes with night I take so positional
95 I take c5 I know doesn't quite work
another time scramble coming No oh he
missed f3
was a draw if some son
[Music]
okay reverse London play the structure
attacking a three before maybe b5 just
fix the pawns in dark space 96 to see
for a force a move it's risky for him
because losses before like position
though
let's see four still looming with 392
thank you miss 92 I was just acting many
times do I have a great gift coming
great gift takes takes a great gift a
surprise great gift whoa okay it's
getting complicated I could take the I
can't take there
I think Mitchell takes h2 h1 takes takes
Queen h4 I think it works
thanks for the Sun I'll give subs and
bit cheers a shout out later I gotta
focus
Queens attacked and Queen h4 scumming g3
it's made into Queen takes d5 Queen h4
g3 takes King g2 Queen h2 mates because
my knight controls f3 one of the other
tricks for white uncie any other tricks
there's no checks I mean there's one
check two checks both of which lose a
queen
thinking what opening to play next game
you'll just stick with my repertoire
so it's first aid in half basically I've
draw lots
[Music]
please
I'm just trying to be solid keep up the
pace with time okay Ford's a little bit
weakening but it's something every III I
should take first what is this oh I'm
still a three Thanks
thank you for the best emote ever and
choose me up every time I use it m Rosen
life is good in Rosen life is good in
Rosen life is good
thanks for that there's t5 in I take and
take
now I shouldn't give away that Bishop
keep the tension I'm threatening to take
in 95 giving square for g3 for my Bishop
g5 ideas
time is not good though
h4 and you want to play CH 5 I Bishop f1
Rick do you want free rook for exchange
play this move 95 94 go for each 595
okay have a pawn storm
I'm King g3 Queen h2 ideas
a risky move I wanna play 94 though
[Music]
[Music]
is that over that's over I think that's
over right in half
nice match Wow
almost flag there it was just about
getting rid of the pawns it's so
stressful
like it was such a close match just had
to be in the zone I'm sorry I couldn't I
wasn't looking at the chat but he had to
get my job done
I don't know if I can message my
opponent or just say thank you my
opponent was also streaming I hope there
is some mods doing some work but wow
it's over
well I'm playing I move on to place
fiddler for the last week I I was trying
to like shut out any thought of the
plains fiddler and just like get through
this match man let me give some
shoutouts Pepe Wow Pepe like joins at
the beginning made tough am I Pepe still
here
the magnet in the chat magnet 22
Oh Pappy a gifting a sub thanks so much
pate two tours 42 I'm playing Svidler
man and after blitz fiddler will also be
commentating hopefully in English if he
commentates in Russian I'll have to
learn Russian just to watch afterwards
guy master gari so many people here
thanks everyone for being here camera
tool I don't know the fourth place
fiddler while being on a roof we have to
schedule the match I assumed it would
take place sometime this month I'm just
trying to stay calm and I mean I do want
to like go over some of those games he
was pretty well prepared in the opening
it was very clear he prepared for me I
prepared for him too
because London preparation was quite
good I didn't get anything so I switched
to English and yeah he played semi Slav
Kings Indian so many people Tommy love
HS so don't worry about us in the chat
while you're playing blitz yeah that's
what I was trying to do yeah English I
mean I kind of figured before the match
he would expect London but I just wanted
to see what his prep was the first two
games I was white he yeah he was he was
quite well prepared but no I I had this
backup line and against the semi slava
c4 takes my c3 line and that I was good
enough to lose get some interesting
positions so this will probably go on
YouTube so for the YouTube people hope
you enjoyed that I think there is
actually a contest or like a prize for
the most liked YouTube video so don't
forget to like the video down below
share it with your friends and family
and enemies
and and yeah for YouTube people thanks
so much for watching I'll see you in the
future